alors maintenant nous voyons c'est
l'interview par amour quand les mouches
marmande égal
bien que par amour
seriez vous prête à sacrifier vos
ambitions professionnelles à part dans
le sud moi ça dépend oui ça c'est bon ça
dépend parce que si quelqu'un t'aime
logiquement pour quoi il demanderait de
sacrifier son travail
moi ça a été même problème avec ma
copine et moi j'adore me faire plein de
nanas et elle voulait que j'arrête
lt mais pas assez je ne vais pas assez
pour pour accepter ça fait bouger tout
c'est pareil bah oui je n'avais pas
assez d'amour par un mot à ce que vous
accepteriez de vous faire refaire le nez
même si le mec cette folle de lui dire
non à temps c'est encore pire demain
premièrement je le ferai pas parce que
par amour qu'ils demandent c'est reparti
n'échoue qu'à rennes puis insultant j'en
écoute je t'aime mais c'est sûr qu'on
reste ensemble sur fait et non moi je
veux rien de faire affaire parce que
j'aurai les boules par rapport à mes
parents battu par tous temps les autres
commerces ça par amour seriez vous prête
à faire ou ne pas faire d'enfant est ce
qu'ils n'en veut pas du tout du tout du
tout oui voilà vaches ouais non ça me
ferait peur ça me ferait peur ouais non
je veux des enfants
suite par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à héberger ses parents ouais je
viens ci-avant d'accord est-ce que alors
ça c'est beaucoup plus grave par amour
est ce que vous seriez prête à l'aider à
cacher le corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient
de tuer
ouais je crois j'aimerais ça
mais même si je n'aime pas par amour est
ce que vous accepteriez qu'il est une
maîtresse
cela m'est déjà arrivé mais c'est dans
des circonstances où toi ça te fait pas
de mal donc où toi tu certainement tu
t'en fous donc c'est pas vraiment là moi
c'est eux
mais si vraiment il est le grand amour
vous auriez du mal à ce qu'ils aient une
vache je suis pas jalouse non non non je
pourrais pas supporter de titres et par
amour est ce que vous seriez prête à
vivre à trois c'est pas pareil zone 3 et
notre île
d'abord avec une autre fille après qu'un
garçon ouais ouais ouais avec une
cheville d'accord
ouais un beau garçon ouais super
évidemment on sent que vous avez une
éducation alors le coeur ce qui n'est
pas le cas toutes les filles alors est
ce que vous seriez prête par amour à
aller le samedi dans un club échangiste
tous les samedis oui non pas tous les
samedis un samedi sur deux je suis
jamais allé donc je crois que ça
m'intrigue ray pas mal une une première
fois juste pour voir mais ça me fait
toujours flipper parce que je sais que
tu peux pas y aller si tu veux pas
participer c'est pas vrai ah bon non
parce que c'est des milf
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
ambiance que tu c'est terriblement mal
sain même temps tu te demande tu vois si
les gens ils parlent avant ou pas parce
qu'ils n'ont même pas bons les
discussions c'est toujours pas pris la
main de corps à corps jamais les
manchots non plus non par amour
est ce que vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle ça n'existait donc
moi je sais pas si c'est drôle tu sais
que je suis comique
immense
ben voyons
3d que j'étais à cannes dans la
sélection
regard voilà